avec mon nom c'est beaucoup nos hommes a
dû quitter l'erythrée à dijon il a
commencé son apprentissage du français
avec la croix rouge puis le dispositif
garanti jeune lui a permis une première
mise en situation professionnelle dans
ce magasin la suite est racontée par son
employeur j'ai été contacté par l'ats
par la garantie jeunes il est venu se
présenter
il a commencé par un premier stage un
stage de un mois suivie d un deuxième
stage d'un mois et ensuite ils intérêt
bas l'équipe est en cdd aujourd'hui on
cdi aujourd'hui c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué de trouver des jeunes baky qui
ont le savoir-faire de ce métier un peu
spécifique donc de pouvoir les avoir en
stage de pouvoir les découvrir les
formes et aussi sur ce métier là c'est
vraiment une chance pour nous un chef
d'entreprise comme ce dispositif
s'adresse aux jeunes entre 16 et 25 ans
qui ne sont ni dans l'emploi ni en
formation durant douze mois la mission
locale leur propose un accompagnement du
logement jusqu'au première expérience
professionnelle en passant par une
allocation du même montant que le rsa et
tout cela avec un certain succès à peu
près 900 jeunes ont intégré la garantie
jeunes et effectivement les résultats
sont plutôt satisfaisants puisque près
de 8 jeunes sur 10 arrive à les en
entreprise pendant cette période et
beaucoup ressorte avec soit des cdd et
les cdi un peu plus rarement quand elle
arrive à toucher les principaux
intéressés la garantie jeune et plutôt
efficace
le bémol c'est que ce droit est loin de
bénéficier à tous ceux qui pourraient y
prétendre
c'est difficile de rentrer en contact
avec ces jeunes qui pour certains sont à
la rue pour d'autres
on ne sait pas vraiment où ils sont il
existe on sait qu'ils existent et donc
vraiment il ya un gros travail de mise
en réseau de tous les de tous les
acteurs qui sont susceptibles de les
croiser association travailleurs sociaux
maison de quartier c'est réunion avait
donc pour but de relancer la
mobilisation afin que le dispositif
bénéficie à tous les jeunes précaires
qui en droit à lui seul l'exemple de
nahum a de quoi galvaniser naoum dont le
destin a déjà basculé deux fois quand il
a fui son pays
et quand il a décroché son cdi